humans have been altering plants and
animals for thousands of years we
started with a process called selective
breeding where organisms that express
desired traits are bred together to pass
on those traits to their offspring the
result of this breeding is all around
you for example early farmers bred for
larger and tastier corn by selectively
planting only corn kernels that came
from corn that was larger and tastier as
humans learned more about the role of
genes and DNA and trait expression we
started developing new techniques for
alterations GMOs or genetically modified
organisms are created by introducing a
gene from another organism or a gene
that has been modified in a lab for
example biotechnologists have created
varieties of corn that are resistant to
the herbicide roundup by introducing a
modified version of a corn gene recently
scientists have developed a whole new
way to alter DNA without introducing new
or modified genes that tool is called
CRISPR cast nine now scientists can
alter corn to be resistant to Roundup by
simply changing the existing genetic
makeup of corn this is much more
efficient and precise than the method of
introducing transgenes
so what is CRISPR cast 9 kes 9 is a
protein that comes from bacteria like
streptococcus pyogenes and functions as
a defense against viruses a virus
invades of bacterium by inserting its
genetic material into the bacterium DNA
to make more copies of itself when
infected with a virus the bacterium
stores a small piece of viral DNA so
that the next time the virus attacks it
can produce an RNA copy which will guide
cast 9 to the invading viral DNA
Kathleen then makes a single
double-stranded cut in the viral genome
learning from streptococcus scientists
have been able to take advantage of this
precise defense mechanism to create
specific edits to
genome let's see how this would work if
scientists wanted to change a mouse's
fur color from black to white scientists
can provide cast name with an RNA
complement containing the gene they want
to modify so that cassadine knows what
DNA to look for here our scientist
provides cast 9 with the RNA complement
of the black for a color gene and
inserts it into a mouse embryo cast 9
that makes a single cuts in the gene and
scientists can make a desired mutation
in one of two ways the first way is just
to hope that the Edit you want occurs by
chance this works surprisingly well the
cut ends of the DNA are fairly unstable
and accidental insertions deletions and
replacements are common scientists
perform CRISPR in a large number of
organisms and then screened the
organisms for the desired
characteristics the second way is to
provide the organism with a template of
the gene with a desired mutation so that
repair enzymes in the organism can use
the template to make exactly the
mutation provided the embryo is placed
back into a mother to finish development
and is born with white fur now that we
understand CRISPR casts 9 we can
envision a myriad of potential
applications gene therapy could be done
in embryos so that babies grow up
without ever experiencing a disease gene
therapy could also potentially be done
in adults through edits to stem cells
which are cells that can develop into
any of the specialized cells in the body
under the right conditions genetic
diseases such as sickle cell and cystic
fibrosis could be prevented researchers
are also experimenting with a new
application of CRISPR to achieve gene
Drive a mechanism that ensures both
chromosomes in an organism received the
same edit so that all of their offspring
and all their offsprings offspring
inherit the mutation with the goal of
forcing that mutation to all members of
a population for example researchers
could eliminate malaria using gene Drive
and mosquitoes
CRISPR is the most powerful gene editing
tool ever seen to date but it is still
in a highly experimental phase there are
no fully developed laws regulating
CRISPR and there are many concerns about
both its practical and moral
consequences as technology continues to
advance researchers lawmakers and the
public will have to decide how to
properly use CRISPR
[Music]
[Music]